puis aussi de trouver au boulevard
haussmann là il y avait devant nous une
centaine de personnes à peu près puisque
on était dans les tous premiers arrivés
vers 10 heures
donc cette centaine de personnes bon je
suis contre le délit de faciès mais on
voyait bien que c'était pas des gilet
jaune qui était devant ça c'est certain
c'était beaucoup de bonnet noir de
d'hommes habillés ils verve et une noire
des blues ont bien tous étaient tous
bien ventru donc qui cachait beaucoup de
choses par dessous les gros ranger des
masques à gaz
tous avaient des masques à gaz mais je
suis montrée monter avec eux mon
mouchoir a les mains dans les poches
une pièce d'identité c'est tout ce que
je recommande est arrivé là boulevard
haussmann l'hélicoptère survolait tous
âges et je me suis rendu compte qu'on
était juste derrière si ces personnes
que j'ai tout de suite vu qu'ils étaient
à l'arrêt pas des bonnes attentions
donc là une dame de la rue de la rue
nous à dia il reste une seule rue est
acteur si disponible pour sortir restez
là donc on est resté là on a attendu
dans ce courrier monter une vague une
vague jaune des centaines des centaines
de de gilet jaune qui était poussé par
la police par toutes les forces de
l'ordre donc on arrivait tous au même
rond point où il y avait une seule rue
qu'on pouvait sauver
et d'un seul coup ça tire et ça tire et
de tous les goûts savait plus qui était
qui et à un moment donné les hommes en
noir que j'appellerais ont fait demi
tour
est-ce à repousser donc les gilet jaune
ne pouvait plus sortir il était pris le
mieux c'est el alaoui c'était mais on a
vu personnellement je n'ai vu rien
d'incendié y avait une fumée on pouvait
rien distinguer donc vous vous êtes
retrouvé en tête
il a seul et unique jeu quand on a
remonté avait une chaire us sur la
droite je suis pas connaître sa peine
une est à peine plus haut que 150 las
une seule rue qui était disponible pour
pour évacuer et ben tout les personnages
et les plus âgés ils nous ont suivi 1
nous ont suivis et après ça s'est il y
avait des petits groupes de deux
centaines de gilet jaune partout on se
déplace énormément à paris il y en avait
partout et à chaque fois c'était ce même
mouvement qui essayait d'atteindre les
champs-elysées mais à pau c'est
impossible donc ce que ces gars là je ne
m'avait pas dit non il n'y en avait
quelques-uns on voyait quand même qui
arrête et on va dire des literies gueule
à parlant publiquement que tout le monde
comprenne mais très peu mais beaucoup
cité des hommes habillés de noir vêtus
de noir est tous avec des masques à gaz
dont qu'il allait d'un faire du mal à
tout ce qui est en ordre et discipline
et cdma lh2 c'est ce que vous dit tout à
l'heure
aussi quand on a dit venus en maillots
quand il voit là quand on voit arriver
des gens bras nus des certains tatouages
rien que par l'habillement on reconnaît
on reconnaît tout de suite les les ai
dit qu'ils étaient très peu donc ça veut
dire que si notre pays est incapable de
protéger les honnêtes citoyens les
artisans les commerçants le le gilet
jaune honnête qui manifestent monsieur
tout le monde ça veut dire qu'une
poignée de jeunes de crapule dirige de
ce qu'est ce que fait l'état
vous êtes déçus non pas du tout pas du
tout je pas des pagnes est déçu du tout
mouillé ça mérite d'être vu même si
c'est choquant c'est choquant de voir
qu'une peau n'y a plus de vauriens
domine ce pays là alors est-ce que c'est
encouragée par l'état voulu parce que je
maintiens que les gens qui ont peur
ben c'est facile à lire faire courber
l'échiné on a demandé m
le trop de plusieurs fois des parisiens
des jeux des mois je tousse tousse
tousse gentiment nous aurait répondu on
a emprunté my métro on n'a eu aucun
souci
donc tout ça c'est fait vous nous fait
croire beaucoup de choses beaucoup de
choses et j'ai vu des gens propres vivre
dans des maisons appartements bord des
trottoirs vraiment ya lieu de
s'interroger ouvre à nouveau
c'était quoi le sentiment avant d'y
aller on va courir en y allant quoi et
le sentiment après avant pour moi
c'était je pensais que le pays était
apte à protéger les honnêtes citoyens
donc vous vous je voulais faire un cran
attendre ce cri de baisse du pouvoir
d'achat de respect des valeurs donc de
marre de toute cette gabegie de l'état
vous de faire entendre le sens du
partage solidarité travail au respect de
tous de tous de tous et puis là j'ai vu
que c'est un désordre c'est le bordel la
france est à cette salle bourdelle plus
rien à voir vous vous crie pour la suite
du mouvement
je crains énormément frédéric énormément
je pense que là on va plus pouvoir
contrôler et que même les gens qui ont
été jusqu alors d'honnêtes citoyens vont
voyant ça ils ont tellement colère
tellement de deux d'années qui sont pas
entendus que ce soir le petit le petit
commerçant qui n'en peut plus que ce
soit le petit salarié qui a donné toute
sa vie de par son travail et qui n'y
arrivent plus donc déjà ces gens là ne
voteront plus parce qu'ils sont écoeurés
écoeuré moi moi personnellement je ne
voterai plus de ce que j'ai vu quatre
non je ne voterai plus donc ça veut dire
que je rejette l'ensemble du système
actuel